Tell me about yourself.
Everything is fine.
How's the situation with your sister?
Fine.
And how's work?
It's fine.
You know what word I'm getting
a little tired of hearing from you, Marty?
The "F" word.
♪ I don't need you to worry for me ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm all right ♪
Everything is not fine.
You're a nice guy.
I'm not gonna let anyone use you.
Therapy works.
It's empowering.
It's liberating.
I feel like I'm on drugs.
I mean, I've never
taken them before, but...
I mean, I assume
this is what drugs feel like.
♪ I don't care what you say anymore ♪
♪ This is my life ♪
Doctor's a little unconventional.
I don't trust him.
♪ Go ahead with your own life ♪
♪ Leave me alone ♪
Marty, I have your
best interest at heart,
but without trust,
we have nothing.
I do trust you.
I trust you completely.
I do believe you have just had
what we headshrinkers call
a breakthrough.
Oh, Jesus.
And we're out of time.
Oh.
♪ Leave me alone ♪